okay everyone so this is the big one
amd's most ambitious attempt to reclaim
Graphics market share so far and you
know what well before I tested the rdna
4 powered RX 970 and 970 XT I was
wondering just what else they could try
I mean in the past we've seen good
performance we've seen competitive
pricing we've seen gigantic cost
reductions on Legacy cards making them
remarkably Valu rfic so what is it going
to take to make rdna 4 any more
successful well there's still going to
be a mountain to climb in terms of Mind
share I guess as the Nvidia brand is so
dominant however going into this one I
think we needed two crucial elements in
the rdna 4 package a viable alternative
to dlss and much much much improved rate
racing performance rdna 4 starts that
Journey with some highly convincing
results and on top of that team red has
delivered impressive pricing so I think
out of the two cards the XT is the one
to have and the cards we're testing
today are the sapphire pure models in
whites no less these are large quiet
well-built cards with Factory overclocks
they're also more expensive than MSRP
the 970 XT here has a sticker price of
$679 an $80 price premium while the non
XT is
$620 a $70 premium over the sticker
price every modern Sapphire card I've
ever had has been quiet and performant
and I've no real quals with either of
these twin PCI 8 Pin power inputs
provide the juice while ports vary from
the standard three display port with one
HDMI configuration here it's two display
port 2.1a along with two HDMI 2.1singles
basically identical but to what extent
do they differ internally quick look at
um rdna 4 specs then and it's all pretty
straight forward the 19970 has 56
compute units up against the full compl
of 64 within the XT model a boost clock
of 2.54 GHz on the non XT up against
2.97 GHz on the XT shows quite a divide
but as you'll see shortly the gap on
these Sapphire models is much tighter
Sapphire seems to taken the non xt's
boost clock up to 2.7 GHz which is not
insignificant while A Small Bump to just
over 3 GHz on the XT won't have that
much of an impact the power differential
is certainly wide though based on the
reference specs 220 wats on the non XT
up against a curiously specific 304
Watts on the new AMD Flagship but expect
those to go higher on these Sapphire
models both cards get 16 GB of memory
surfaced by a
256bit memory interface there's no gddr
7 like Nvidia AMD is sticking with G6
let's kick off with a look at power
consumption on these Sapphire cards
clock speed and some performance numbers
um up against their immediate Nvidia
counterparts kicking off with black myth
Wukong here BMW we're seeing that 970 XT
is knocking on the door of 5070 TI
Performance Based on this sequence 91 %
of the 5070 TI frame rates but requires
33% more power to do it that's a
remarkably High 6.3 Jews per frame
against nvidia's 4.3 Jews per frame on
the 9070 non XT power drops
significantly and performance across the
whole bench is similar to the vanilla
5070 but AMD requires 133% more power to
achieve pretty much the same result 5.4
jws per frame on non XT versus 4.8 on
Nvidia clock speeds Ross the board here
are in the 2.7 GHz range with the
exception of 970 XT which runs the gamut
from 2.8 GHz to just over 3 GHz
depending on content Hitman with no rate
tracing active tends to favor AMD
architectures and here the 970 XT beats
5070 TI by around 5% but to do that it's
requiring 16% more power two Jews per
frame from AMD versus 1.8 on Nvidia so
the impression so far is that for am MD
to get competitive with Nvidia on the
higher end a good deal more power is
required the situation in this game is
much Rosier on the non XT though is 21%
faster than the vanilla 5070 and
requires just 2.6% more power 1.7 je per
frame from AMD up against two JS per
frame on Nvidia interestingly clock
speeds are much lower on this title with
the XT only rarely moving above 2.8 GHz
with non XT about 150 slower switching
over to Hitman similarly maxed but this
time with all RT features enabled the
97t XT has around 94% of the performance
of the 5070 TI but requires 27% more
power to get there so I'm continuing to
get the sense that AMD pushed the XT
really hard to get it as close to Nvidia
as possible 4.2 Jews per frame from the
XT versus 3.1 on 5070 TI again the
situation flips on the 9070 non XT
beating 5070 by 133% in frame rate terms
but it is using 10% more power 3.5 jws
per frame up against 3.6 on Nvidia
looking at a game that does actually
favor Nvidia Dying Light 2 here sees the
970 XT only delivering 82% of 570 TI's
performance and requiring 20% more power
to do so I'm measuring a remarkable 10.4
je per frame on the XT versus 7.1 on the
ti next up the 5070 versus 970 Faceoff
at 9.1 J per frame the 970 has 94% of
5070 performance but still requires 7%
more power that brings in Nvidia around
7.9 Jews per frame also interesting to
note here is that this heavy RT workload
has sent GPU core clocks on rdna for
tumbling ultimately it's difficult to
avoid the sense that amds pushing the XT
re really hard to get close to the TI's
level of performance while non-xt is
more efficient more competitive in that
sense with the 5070 so at this point in
a GPU review We crack on with benchmarks
right but we've also been quite vocal
about how relevant they are Beyond a raw
apples to apples hardware test in a
world where software where upscaling is
becoming more important more crucial and
where Nvidia has held a big big
Advantage for getting on for 5 years now
but at CES we saw FSR 4 and we were
impressed seriously impressed and on the
channel now we have a first look at the
final version of the technology and it's
really good really good perhaps not up
to dlss Transformer model quality
standards in all respects but marketly
better than dss3 in key scenarios so I
do recommend checking out that video and
we'll have a more detailed analysis
further on down the line and so with
that crucial question answered for now
it's time to look look at that Hardware
performance via benchmarking Apples to
Apples it is but obviously there are
differences in the feature sets of both
cards also as with any Benchmark don't
take these numbers to mean that game X
runs FPS Y for the whole duration it's
all about the performance differentials
at match settings with a view to
establishing some kind of hierarchy here
AMD calls these products 4K cards at
1440p pricing so we'll be using 4K as
the primary resolution choice if you're
into maxing out 1440p will be the better
choice overall for all cards tested here
and we have all of those numbers and
More in our accompanying Euro gamer
review complete with those interactive
bar charts so looking at Avatar
frontiers of Pandora first of all well a
fascinating result between the fastest
and slowest cards 570 TI and 5070
respectively there's a 30% differential
570 TI obviously comes out tops here but
delivers just a 6.6 6% increase in
performance over the 9070 XT the non XT
has 91% of the xt's performance while
beating the 5070 by 11% yes this is a
weaker game for Blackwell but it's rare
to see Nvidia being beaten by AMD in a
rracing title at the same price point
now let's take a look at how rdna 4
compares to higher end rdna 3 and the
results are intriguing 7900 XTX here is
top of the pack commanding an
eight-point lead over the 9070 XT rising
to almost 19 points clear of the non XT
the 7900 XT bound to be heavily
discounted at this point beats out the
9070 non XT by three points while the
9070 XT is 7% faster than the old XT
cyberpunk 2077 with psycho RT active now
otherwise running fully maxed down this
is a game toed for NVIDIA hardware and
it shows with the 570 TI streets ahead
of the9 1970 XT to the tune of
24% there's a 16% gap between 9070 non
XT and the XT model but it's perhaps no
surprise to see that the 5070 does inch
ahead of 970 though the 5.6% Gap isn't
exactly huge right amd's RT enhancements
for rdna 4 are clear to see in the Gen
on gen comparisons well I say gen on gen
but this is high-end rdna 3 versus
mainstream rdna 4 of course both cards
beat XTX and XT 970 XT beats out XTX by
a remarkable
24% while the 9070 non XT also has a
24-point lead this time over 7900 XT
Dying Light 2 next and we've had a
preview of that already but the 570 TI
keeps up its impressive RT Advantage
with a 21-point lead over 9070 XT which
itself offers up a 14o advantage over
the non-xt in this one the 5070 has a
6.6% lead over non XT an interesting
note on this particular Benchmark though
the first half is considerably more
detail rich and Nvidia actually widens
the performance differential in that
part with AMD making up for lost ground
in the secondary less detail intensive
area of the sequence and meanwhile an
interesting spread looking at rdna 4
versus rdna A3 970 XT does beat the
older XTX but only by around
2.5% the non XT can't beat the XTX here
but it's 6.5% clear of the 7900 XT f124
next bar rain in the rain all settings
maxed RT features fully armed and
operational interesting stuff here I
noted a deficiency in performance on
5070 so the ramifications versus rdna A4
are intriguing RTX 570 TI and 9070 XT
jle for position at the top of the table
but ultimately by the the time the bench
ends both have the same result that also
means that the 970 non XT shines it
commands a 16 percentage point lead over
the RTX 55070 which doesn't quite make
it to the podium on this one it's a game
that performed surprisingly well on rdna
A3 so perhaps no surprise that the
percentage gains are relatively small
the new XT is just six points to the
better against the old XTX however the
groupings are tight so the 7900 XT is
beaten by the new non XT to the tune of
5% may come as no surprise to learn that
there's a 14% differential between the
two new AMD offerings Hitman world of
assassination really is a tough workout
so a really good Apples to Apples test
between Nvidia and AMD 570 TI still wins
but it's a 4.8% lead which will surely
ruffle feathers within Team Green
bearing in mind the price differential
by extension that's bad news for the Bas
5070 where the nonex beats it by just
over 10% looking at prior generation
high-end rdna 3 both the 9070 non XT and
the XTX have a 14 to 15 Point advantage
over 7900 XT which is pretty impressive
non XT matching last gen XTX in turn
that gives the 9070 XT 15 percentage
point lead over the old AMD Flagship and
that's pretty good going I'd say bearing
in mind the price cut you're getting
from the XTX to the new XT in this
demanding test I'm seeing a 16o
difference between the two rdna 4 cards
in favor of the XT of course very
similar to Hitman Indiana Jones and the
great circle also shows very impressive
numbers for AMD 19970 XT is beaten once
again by the RTX 570 TI but will you
actually miss that extra 5.3% of
performance bearing in mind the price
differential this time the new XT only
out scores the non XT by around 10% that
strong performance which extends to the
cheaper AMD offering beating the 5070 by
133% looking at the second group test
rdna 3 versus rdna 4 it's no surprise to
see the 7900 XT at the bottom of the
pile XTX beats it by 14% with the new XT
inching ahead of that ever so slightly
this leaves 970 XT in Champion standing
overall 16% ahead of XTX 15 points clear
of the 97 non XT let's move on to Metro
Exodus enhanced Edition now the first
triaa game that required a GPU capable
of Hardware accelerated R tracing and
another game that has typically
underperformed to a certain extent on
nvidia's Blackwell architecture as it
does here actually where the RTX 570
Masters a py
1.7% performance advantage over RX 970
XT that spells trouble of course for the
vanilla non on TI RTX 570 where the 9070
non-xt Powers ahead with a 13 a half
percentage Point Advantage I mean this
is an older catalog game where there is
dlss support and where there is no FSR
or xss alternative but even so as a test
of raid facing prowess the claxons
should be going off of Nvidia so how far
has AMD come well Metro was developed to
run nicely on rdna2 consoles remember
and it did hold up on rdna A3 7900 XT is
the weakest card here in the second
group test and the 970 non XT only
delivers a 5.5% lead rising to 16.8%
against the XTX which is essentially
running at the same speed overall as the
970 XT returning to an area where AMD
has traditionally performed extremely
well let's take a look at some
rasterization benchmarks as we return to
Blackmouth ruk Kong a highly demanding
area of the game well there is the
situation of Blackwell raster
performance seemingly being more
improved than RT so let's see how this
shakes out I mean the numbers don't lie
570 TI has a 10 percentage point lead
over 9070 XT but this time the non XT
and the RTX 570 perform much the same
across the duration of The Benchmark XT
versus non-xt based on this snippet of
action the higher end AMD card has an
11-point advantage on the second group
test I'm seeing very very similar
performance across the entire iry of The
Benchmark when we're comparing 7900 XT
against 970 non XT meanwhile XTX is
emerging as the Victor overall though
it's just a 3% lead over amd's new
mid-range Flagship the 970 XT fors of
horizon 5 next and a similar
rasterization story a 10-point lead for
the RTX 570 TI over the 19970 XT while
the non XT does beat the vanilla 5070
but it's a mere here threo Advantage
focusing on the new cards the XT is
faster than non XT as you might imagine
but the Gap is just 5.3% based on other
results also a sense of deja vu looking
at the prior gen group test of course
the 7900 XT is last with the 970 non XT
delivering a Sixpoint lead over that
however it's interesting to note that
the XTX beats the new XT but you know
it's only by around 2% our final
rasterization test returns us to unreal
Engine 5 uh this time for senu Saga
hellblade 2 one of the finest Graphics
showcases we've seen in this generation
and while the Gap isn't huge across one
of the longest Benchmark sequences we
have 970 XT isn't just competitive with
RTX 570 TI It inches ahead with a 2.5
percentage point lead which leaves the
vanilla 570 in a bit of a pickle the non
XT batters it with a 16.5 Point
Advantage once again today's mainstream
rdna 4 offers ballpark higher end last
gen rdna 3 rasterization frame rates
non-xt rdna A4 beats the 7900 XT by 2.6%
but the tables flip in a totally
undramatic way as the XTX eaks out a 2.2
percentage point lead over the 970 XT
let's summarize a little bit here and
break out Benchmark results focusing on
RT exclusively first of all I don't make
a habit of this uh because ultimately
both AMD and Nvidia have been making RT
cards for over four years now I consider
RT to be an absolute fixture now but you
know obviously this is an area where the
radon cards needed to improve across all
games tested to all resolutions I have
the RTX 570 TI having an 8% RT advantage
over the 9070 XT but remember it's MSRP
is significantly higher meanwhile the
tables turn with the non XT versus the
5070 AMD has a 5.5% RT advantage over
Nvidia just bear in mind that we are
looking at a significant Factory
overclock from Sapphire there on this
970 aggregating raster and RT results
together again across all resolutions
570 TI beats 970 XT by 3% while the
non-xt the factory overclocks one
remember bests the reference Beck
Founders Edition 5070 by 9% and again
using all benchmarks at all resolutions
aggregated here's how the frames per
dollar calculations pan out 9070 XT
offers a touch more value than the 9070
but not by as huge an amount as many may
have feared on these Sapphire models I
tested the deficit in boost clock
between the two cards at reference spec
is far less pronounced in real world
testing so yeah this is obviously going
to be having an impact on the value
scores here 5070 isn't a million miles
away from 9070 even so but the gap
between the XT and the 57 TTI pretty
vast All Things Considered bottom line
though in terms of Hardware capabilities
at least AMD is back to winning ways and
this time the key compromises of subpar
rate tracing performance and relatively
poor upscaling quality are greatly
mitigated on the subject of upscaling
though it is is worth remembering that
dlss has far far more support more games
support dlss frame generation over FSR 3
while amd's anti-ag 2 technology is
nowhere near as prevalent as nvidia's
reflex and that Transformer model from
Nvidia is stupendously good but I do
wonder how long it'll take for AMD to
catch up bearing in mind how impressive
FSR 4 is for a first effort the Green
Team can of course look towards its past
facing titles and you know they do run
on AMD but not to the same level of
performance even now um and of course a
key feature Ray reconstruction AMD is
working on an alternative but you know
in the here and now they don't have it
in addition to things like dollars per
frame these features do need to be
included in any purchasing decision but
the extent to which they are important
to you is a matter of taste of course
right now at least I'd say this is the
strongest AMD challenge against Nvidia
I've seen in years years and I look
forward to seeing how the face off
continues into the budget heartlands but
that's all for me for now so yeah it's
the same old story right like subscribe
share if you enjoyed the content ring
bells for instant notifications for you
and a likely algorithmic boost for us
and yeah as always I can't help but
Champion the DF supporter program high
quality video downloads a brilliant
Community News updates from the team
Early Access opportunities plus you get
to see DF weekly a couple of days ahead
of everyone else ultimately the
supporter program is what makes digital
Foundry possible so here we are then at
the end of the video assuming you're
still watching it so from me to you
thanks for watching and supporting
digital Foundry
[Music]